i'm david reading for reviewer mark
delaney every august a new madden
launches with some major marketing
buzzword attached it makes for easy back
of the box material and quickly answers
the question what's new in madden this
year
these named features often fail to live
up to the proper noun naming conventions
but in madden nfl 23 that's not the case
this year's buzzwordy feature fieldsense
encompasses several other features under
its wide umbrella with all of them
relating to how it feels to actually
play and move around on the field in
that regard mata 23 is a clear step up
but several other aspects of the game
including both returning issues and new
problems keep the game from achieving
its full potential at launch field sense
is not one feature but the name for a
collection of on-field improvements
among them the biggest and most
enjoyable leap forward is the new
skill-based passing system this system
is meant to remove some of madden's
attribute driven outcomes and transfer
decisiveness to the player on the field
this is done by giving players a new
throwing meter and shadowed target area
that appears as the ball is being thrown
it allows players to pinpoint directly
where they want the ball to go a bit
like fielding in mlb the show excitingly
this feature lives up to its promise
allowing skilled players to skewer
defenses and hit gaps in coverage like
never before in madden history a wonky
tutorial though does this feature no
good making practice best done in a live
setting after a few quarters of games
with skill based passing enabled it
becomes blatantly obvious that going
back to the old system while an option
in madden 23 is never a good idea it
allows the qb to keep a pass in front of
the cornerback on a crossing route hit
back shoulder fades in the end zone and
sneak into the space between two
defender zones in ways that in years
past almost always resulted in turnovers
i'd go so far as to say that madden 23
is worth playing just for this feature
alone because throwing the football
something that you'll do 15 to 40 times
per game has never felt so good field
sense also applies to other aspects of
the game including new tackling
mechanics that remove some canned
animations and give defense a more
physics based feeling this too feels
better than before but it does result in
a number of silly looking tackles as a
result with more ragdoll-like players
sometimes performing ridiculous falls
the game is better off with the style
however as the game's old shoestring
tackles and pre-canned wrap-ups where
you knew whether or not you got the
first down before the play ended are
fewer and farther between
making cuts with ball carriers also
feels better allowing a skilled player
to ease off the sprint button at the
line making a great cut through the hole
then taking off and leaving defenders
out of position this applies to kick and
punt returns too which are suddenly not
wrote 25 yard returns anymore in my
first week with the game i've seen a
more realistic array of outcomes on
returns many get passed even well past
the 25 now including some touchdowns
which previously felt almost impossible
despite that being unrealistic
the past russian madden 23 is amped up
too in a way that helps contain the
franchise's legacy issues of a qb having
an entire lunch break's worth of time to
throw the ball
pressure can be generated with even just
three or four rushers if they're good at
their jobs helping bring madden closer
to reality where cubies tend to only
have about two to four seconds at most
to get rid of the ball ai pass rushers
also smartly disengage blockers when the
player qb applies the sprint button
signaling that they intend to scramble
out of the pocket collectively this
helps tame some of madden's most
meta-defining but unrealistic play calls
where a shifty passer would wiggle over
to the sideline avoid the rush entirely
and wait for a wideout to beat a
defender on a comeback route 5 or more
seconds into the play madden 23 is a
better on-field experience without a
doubt but some of its modes and
peripheral features are still lacking in
such a way that feels unfathomable for
one of the world's biggest video games
based on one of the world's biggest
brands
in madden ultimate team or mutt new
field passes have been added which act
as free battle passes that reward you
more consistently game by game week by
week these are meant to appease the
crowd that decries mud as a pay to win
only and while they are helpful the mode
is still a mess of microtransactions
where one player can grind for 40 hours
to buy a card that another player can
just purchase at will on top of that
though the field pass rewards come often
they're dispersed unevenly and only
after frustration you might need to play
one more game to complete a challenge
and earn your next field pass reward but
at the end of the game there's currently
a guaranteed delay in when you actually
get the reward which is silly even worse
the reward screens are constantly buggy
revealing no information the game will
often just briefly sit at a purple pink
background screen as though you're given
pertinent information but it winds up
being more like a loading screen never
showing you what you actually unlocked
until minutes or even full games later
the fieldpass system is meant to copy
mlb the show's programs which are cited
as the reason it's card collecting mode
is the best in the sports gaming world i
can see how madden's field passes could
be similarly game changing because
earning more frequent and better cards
for free is certainly a welcome feature
because this is the first year that i
plan to put hours into mutt after review
season so it must be doing something
right but right now broken menus that
share no information and rewards that
come too late take what was meant to be
gaming's latest overt skinner scheme and
turns it into a jumbled mess of systems
that feel undercooked which is a bummer
in franchise mode the big changes come
during the offseason where more control
over college scouting and more chaos and
free agency are meant to deepen the
experience free agents will now consider
more than just money and team prestige
when deciding where to sign they'll also
take into account factors such as
where'd they'd be on the depth chart
whether a team placed close to their
home town whether the team has an elite
qb or super bowl chances and even
whether or not the state takes income
taxes these are fun additives but mostly
just reimagine the previous system
expanding a free agent's list of
relevant factors from 3 to about 8.
the scouting improvements are more
crucial including the way your automated
scouts now reveal pertinent information
to each prospect you don't really need
to know a receiver's tackling ability
for example but after last year's big
scouting update introduced this system
such unnecessary data were exactly what
you would get
this year scouts will hone in on the key
attributes that matter to each position
you're looking at giving you a better
sense of each player come draft day
franchise does still struggle from two
things introduced last year though for
one the pre-game team scouting report is
still liable to share
totally wrong information in theory
knowing a team's tendencies to for
example throw it short middle or deep
you know gives you an excellent
advantage in practice it doesn't matter
when the game is so often displaying
false data even as it seems designed to
only base its numbers on the previous
game which itself is an issue as game
plans can vary wildly in a league full
of more human players than ai the
frustrating and annoying m-factor system
returns and seems once more to be unable
to be toggled on or off
last year m-factors were introduced as a
way to gamify momentum swings by giving
teams certain boosts like better ball
security or negatively affecting the
opponent's ability to call hot routes
unlike x factors which do well to
simulate the way that an elite player
can take over a game or a moment
m factors are just arcadey messes that
have no real world counterparts in a
series striving for authenticity it is
odd that this unrealistic feature
returns as an untouchable element to
games especially since franchise mode
can be so customizable in many other
ways the story heavy face of the
franchise mode continues to feel
directionless ever since the
unintentionally goofy long shot
storyline was introduced back in madden
18 the team has struggled to deliver a
story mode worth playing
seeking to rival nba 2k's much better my
player mode the last few years have
taken a more laissez-faire approach
giving players story snippets but not
putting them on rails like longshot did
the result is once more forgettable this
time the premise has you signing a
one-year prove it deal after your rookie
contracts team option wasn't picked up
it's a novel way to start the story
since they so often focus on rising
stars or injury-hampered rookies but in
the end there's just not enough here to
justify the mode's inclusion the end
goal is to join madden's 99 club which
you can do in just a few seasons and
without much story at all and my first
instance of the story mode i was
strangely traded just two games into the
preseason which seemed to reduce the
amount of story content i even saw after
that causing me to start over just so i
could know if this was a scripted moment
which it wasn't apparently and it left
me wondering why it's even possible it's
routinely felt like face of the
franchise is developed to merely check a
box and this annual half measure brings
nothing of value to the mode in madden
23 but a lot of cringe yes sir
i mean i don't know unless you really
like running up the stat line with your
custom player every single week and even
in that case you're better off playing
franchise unless you also enjoy playing
the yard which is once again affected
directly by your player's skill
increases in the story mode and face of
the franchise the yard itself returns
virtually unchanged it's a short game
6v6 arcade like mode for players who
don't enjoy the sim heavy aspects and
want something a bit closer to the long
dormant nfl street since it was added
two years ago the yard has dwindled in
importance quickly seemingly because
much of the community ignores it
therefore madden 23's instance of the
mode feeds this endless cycle players
ignore it so it receives fewer
meaningful updates which in turn causes
players to ignore it even more and so on
the yard is at least present though
whereas superstar ko has virtually been
removed from the experience diluted down
to a limited time mode that plays quite
like it within mutt but seems destined
to rotate in and out of the game all
year
in total this year's madden is a lot
like the past decade of madden and that
it suffers a number of self-inflicted
wounds and returns features that were
unpopular in years prior however it's
crucial to reiterate on the field that
madden's gameplay genuinely feels great
for the first time in a long time the
changes to franchise are helpful but not
revolutionary the mudfield pass system
is promising but is very janky at launch
and other modes are well largely
forgettable
this would all present quite a
lackluster view of the game if not for
the impressive on-field leap that it
performs the improvements on game day
make madden 23 a very flawed game but
clearly an improvement in the series
most important way the actual playing of
football
[Music]
[Music]
you